Jon Stewart sat down with Gavin Newsom
Gavin Newsom who has demolished the
state of California
and Jon Stewart slightly to his credit
here went after Newsom a little bit but
then kind of excused most of it because
what's happening right now in California
is first off they're taking felons
they're lowering them to misdemeanors
they're putting less people in jail
they're letting more people out of jail
Petty crimes aren't going to jail you
can trespass they won't arrest you a
certain amount of drugs they won't
arrest you you guys get the the amount
of things that this leads to and the
Decay that has happened in Cali which is
why so many people are fleeing but
here's uh Stewart basically massaging uh
Gavin newsom's record over crime and and
allow giving him in essence a past but
it's not it's not horrific but it's
mostly pretty bad
the system isn't built
to cherish each individual and get them
to see their own worth no this is built
to keep them from killing each other
while they're in here correct but as a
society you're right we have to actually
believe in the core tenets of what we
practice in our faith right in that
second damn chances and Redemption Mary
Reese you wanted uh to commute her
sentence you sent her back to a parole
board she's been in prison for a series
of burglaries not nothing but clearly
not a violent offender right she failed
her parole hearing based on having
borrowed I think hair gel from another
prisoner and some other things and on
the flip side of it you have an offender
who was let out and killed a police
officer yeah recently
devastating devastating yeah that
person that killed the police officer
the district attorney
accuse me being responsible that's right
for that I live the reality I don't know
them it's not intellectual that's a
living sure and that puts you on your
heels
actually put me on my toes right you
want reform and you want to be prepared
I want Public Safety I want real Public
Safety I want people to feel safe it's
about your own self-interest right it's
so interesting to me it's about your own
self-interest Gavin Newsom doesn't give
a about anyone's self-interest in
California after what he's done for the
last couple years and what he's done on
crime and the way he destroyed San
Francisco and Johnson were pointing out
oh yeah you're right on that one dude
but the first part the opening part of
that clip is what the most interesting
part is and then I think this goes to
what the flaw and why I think it
actually is to some degree a spiritual
issue here not a political issue Jon
Stewart opened that by saying the system
isn't built to cherish these people and
get them to see their own worth
well that's not what the system is
designed to do our system because we are
all flawed people hoping to build a
system that will just protect our
individual rights things that Gavin
Newsom doesn't care about our system was
built to do three things in essence it
was one thing really but protect what
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness protect life we're going to
make sure we have a police force and an
army so people can't invade and your
murderer is not going to show up at your
house Liberty your ability we're going
to protect Liberty you will decide who
you want to communicate with who you
want to have in your inner circle what
you will want in your local community
that's Liberty how you will live your
life what you want to go pursue and then
of course the pursuit of happiness not
the guarantee of happiness but because
we will make sure that you're not going
to get killed to the best of our ability
and we'll make sure that you can do what
you want to do hopefully or at least try
to go for that then you can pursue
happiness wouldn't that be sweet
wouldn't that be sweet and that was
although it may sound old and it was
written by a bunch of old white people
who are long since gone it was pretty uh
Innovative for its time and it still
stands the test of time
[Music]